[Music]
we miss clarissa I'm gonna tell your
girl in that dress you looking about as
sweet as a field full of honeysuckle
after a spring rain shower how do you do
it girls dad a snow what was that what
was what what you just said to her oh I
was just following Yoli
no you wasn't you will being all
heavy-handed with it man you gotta be
subtle
exactly you gotta be subtle you want to
talk to them later I can do that mr.
nice you're the way that dress is
flowing you look like a Mountain Creek
after the spring thaw simply refreshing
what if yo secret wait a dress fitting
on you get them titties popping out what
amazing what if yo secret what are you
doing I was just doing what you were
doing show you what I even said what if
yo secret that's what oblate them that
part was did you hear me say anything
about anybody's titties
no you know what how about we just say
no words Oh
together no words altogether mm-hmm
question you how will I talk you're not
gonna talk okay
all right ladies I'm sorry y'all hurt my
eyes y'all just like smoldering like the
Sun and just as bright and then
beautiful dress mmm
[Music]
vagina what the hell was that oh I did
say a word at the end here didn't I did
you see the part with all this was going
on and shaking the tail feathers and
whatnot I didn't see it I got the worst
view in the house
that's what chased them away man all
right you know what stay away from me
all right who miss the Vern you like a
long-stemmed Rose the way you looking
and smelling mm-hmm
what is your recipe damn boy
how about you got a big old digging ball
I love you
[Music]
you